okay
all right sweet pea sweet pea where were
you from where'd you grow up originally
culver
tell me about your childhood you have
both your parents growing up no
i was raised by my grandma and then when
she died i was raised by my aunt
what happened to mom and dad my mom was
on the street homeless and my father
wasn't in the picture
and how was your childhood it was all
right spoiled
gotta go to disneyland all those places
growing up so yeah
no traumatic events no abuse
just standards sitting in the corner
that's about it yeah
what kind of kid were you in high school
said it again what kind of kid were you
in high school
um i was always to myself so
it's like a tomboyish
you were popular or you were no it
wasn't popular
and then at what point did you what age
did you leave home
i didn't leave home until i was 18.
where'd you go
i was in arizona
and when did you start working as a
prostitute two weeks ago
oh is that right yeah oh so this is new
for you
all right so let's back up it's not
really new it's just
uh i just upgraded i guess i don't know
that's my first time for having a pimp
so
so um so what have you been doing up
until two weeks ago
living on the street living life i guess
yeah
dealing with dramatic people immature
people yeah drugs are part of your life
right
um yeah fentanyl and crystal you're
smoking fentanyl in
crystal net how long has that been going
on
the crystal's been going on for the last
couple years
since 2018 and then the fetty since
last year of october and money got tight
and you realized you could make more
money no because i always got it for
free
oh i said
what helped you make the decision to
work with with a pimp no
um money advisor or financial
money for a financial advisor whatever
and so he helps you with your money yeah
how much how much of your money do you
give them
i give them all my money and what do you
what do you
what is he doing with it he puts it into
what we like the rent and then he puts
into whatever we need
so you'll he'll help you find guys or
how do you guys
find business i walk the truck
figaro street no what's what streets do
you work
separate okay the valley
so two weeks into it how do you first
two weeks gone
all right
are you liking it are you adjusting to
it or you i'm adjusting to it
what's the hardest part um
just finding the dates avoiding police i
guess um
yeah and you realize it's a dangerous
lifestyle
and all that right it is
but it's different experience so
that's for sure
i mean there's a chance of you getting
arrested there's a chance you're getting
beaten up
all that kind of stuff
true but as long as we know what we need
to do none of that would happen
how much money are you making at night
it depends
and you you're you're okay with giving
away your money and knowing
hoping that it's going to come back one
day or if you need it
it'll be whatever i need he gets it from
me so
what's to keep you from doing it by
yourself without a pimp
i wouldn't be doing it at all
if i didn't have my pimp
or am i dating
dear kids yeah i have two and were they
with my adopted mom my aunt in arizona
do you talk to them
so you're basically just kind of living
on your own with your pimp mm-hmm
is this i mean so you're living either
living on the street or you're in hotels
or
no we we live in a hotel so
i live with him my daddy yeah
you think you're happy yeah you okay
with
this life
do you have any plans for your future
hopefully get my girls back
how old are they ten and three
the queen of drugs will be a hard thing
to kick right
no i could do it i just choose not to do
it
what's what's stopping you from from
getting clean and
getting back together with your kids and
being their mom nothing
just myself i guess
do you think it's something that do you
think it's some kind of
self-worth issue or or what do you think
the biggest
block is for you from doing that because
what you're doing now is certainly not
a lifestyle that is good for your kids
or for you well my family doesn't know
about what i'm doing
so
when my girls are too young to know what
this is
and i wouldn't let them do this when
they get older
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing about drug addiction and
sex work is for people that don't do it
everybody's answer's different i i mean
making money is making money at the end
of the day you look at it
when did you first get introduced to
drugs
when i was twenty-three
a banana started doing it so i was
twenty-four
how do you know thirty
what was the best time in your life
growing up not having to worry about
doing
paying bills or paying rent or nothing
like that
and what was what was the the roughest
part of your
of your life
it wasn't family members i'm sorry
losing family losing family
do you think you're addicted to this
this life is the street
drugs sex work life no no
you can walk away tomorrow if i could
yeah
have you had relationships before you've
been married never married
you've been alive i mean i'm in love
with my pen
i do love him how'd you meet him
i met him with a mutual friend
so i've got my we got i got our friend
to thank for meeting each other so yeah
how long have you known him um
about a couple a couple weeks now almost
a month
we've known each other for a couple for
like a couple of weeks
and almost a month about a month but i
only
i barely started working for him for two
weeks he's got you working for him
having sex with guys and that's that
works for you
in a relationship it makes money for us
so yeah
can you can you imagine a relationship
where
maybe your partner's a little more
supportive and and helps your
you know more concerned about your
safety or your your family i know
he's concerned about my safety that's
why before i get a data we send them i
always take some dollar signs
and then i let them know that i'm then
i'm gonna be on my way back
just take care of business get the money
and come back
that's it
i'm not in danger i'm safe
and i'm in good hands the relationships
you had with men
before him how were those relationships
abusive
abusive
didn't give two [ __ ] about me at the
end of the day
do you do you see that maybe there's
something that you're doing or decisions
you're making that might be
leading to that can abuse
just getting into relationships that are
abusive right do you think it's just bad
luck or do you think it's there's
something you're doing that's creating
it
it's just being with somebody that's
doing that's
their heads feel like because they're in
the drug cloud they're in the cloud so
all their mind is about just don't more
think you can get out of it
and you take any responsibility for
getting into those situations or you
just think it's just
you need a bunch of jerks i just happen
to meet a lot of [ __ ]
do you have any goals for your life
let's get my girls back other than your
kids i mean like a career or anything
you'd love to do
go back to school did you finish high
school
nope no how far did you get 11th grade
i've been on my own since i was 18 so
you've been arrested before
no for drugs no
other things
does your pimp have plans of like maybe
taking you to las vegas or
other areas like that to make more money
we're not on that subject yet but when
it comes to it
we don't i don't know
and the guys you pick up they'll you
guys will go to a
motel or go to the car or where you guys
do business the car or sometimes you use
the room
how much money do you make typically
if it's a good day make up to 500
sometimes
if it's a bad day it's one day maybe
like last night i made like 3 50. and
how much do you spend on
meth and fentanyl a day
don't spend that much just so
i don't have to buy it because he
provides it for me
if something could be different about
your life today what would
what would you want that to be
nothing i'm happy where i'm at and what
i'm doing
what do you think about i mean if your
parents were in your life as a kid do
you think
you'd be in a different place today it's
hard to say
what lessons have you learned in your
life
um a lot
i don't know
[Music]
is there anything in your life you're
passionate about
i want to go to school become a mechanic
but yeah right now my line of work is
hoeing prostituting
what would you say to your family your
kids or your parents if they were around
about where you're at today this is
temporary
i wouldn't say nothing to them like
because i would have i don't
i wouldn't be able to face them
there's a lot of shame yeah a little bit
part of me yeah has a guilty conscience
but
part of me is like doing this because
i want to i guess
do you find there's something you enjoy
about it
the attention from men or no just making
the money
are you concerned about the future your
kids will have because you're not around
no i know they're going they're doing
they're in good hands
they're doing they're going to do good
all right all right sweet people thank
you for talking to me
good luck thank you
you